wo ist rebecca reusch wenn ein mord
nicht aufgeklärt wird dann leiden die
angehörigen ihr leben lang
ermittlerteams die kämpfen darum fälle
auch nach jahrzehnten zu lösen und den
familien der opfer so wenigstens ein
kleines bisschen gerechtigkeit zu geben
und genau darum soll es heute in dieser
sendung gehen in unserem achtung
förderung cold case spezial unser erster
fall abend für abend da wiederholt sich
in einem hellgelben einfamilienhaus hier
in berlin rudow das immer selber ritual
bevor brigitte rösch einschläft da betet
sie und sendet ihrer jüngsten tochter
rebecca liebe kraft und mut denn ihre
bikini ist seit drei jahren spurlos
verschwunden rebeccas schwager florian
der ist bis heute im visier der
ermittler denn die beamten die sind sich
sicher der mann der hat in seinen
vernehmungen gelogen
[Musik]
liebe euch
15 das berliner mädchen mit den blonden
haaren sie liebt es videos uns hilft zu
machen so wie viele andere ganz normale
teenager
sie wächst in einer handwerkerfamilie
auf ist die jüngste von drei töchtern
laut ihrer eltern ist sie lebenslustig
liebevoll der sonnenschein der familie
[Musik]
nach dieser sonnenschein ist verblasst
seit dem 18 februar 2009 10 gibt es von
ihr kein lebenszeichen mehr
wie kann es sein dass ein 15 jähriges
mädchen in einer großstadt wie berlin
einfach so verschwindet
warum gibt es nicht diese eine spur die
verbindlich verrät was mit ihr passiert
ist wurde rebecca opfer eines
verbrechens wurde ihr leichnam in den
unübersichtlichen wäldern brandenburgs
versteckt was ist mit becky wie sie von
ihrer familie genannt wird geschehen
ob wir irgendwelche hinweise finden
eventuell was von ihr was sie bei hatte
er telefoniere jakob hier irgendwas
entsorgt wurde ist sie einfach
weggelaufen warum auch immer die
ermittler haben eine schlimme verdacht
das ist die kriminalistische erfahrung
die wir hier
berücksichtigen müssen
wir haben umfangreiche ermittlungen
geführt wurden keine hoffnung mehr dass
rebecca noch lebt über 2000 hinweise bis
heute massive maßnahmen der polizei
private sucht initiative unzählige
vermisst seiten in sozialen netz
erfolglos bis jetzt
eine antwort auf die frage wo
[Musik]
wird berlin chefreporter matthias becker
begleitet diesen kriminalfall von
anbeginn bis heute
wo ist rebecca
die spur führt in den wald
wir finden dich
acht jahre arbeitet matthias becker als
unbezahlbar und wird dann journalist der
vorbeter verging bis heute der
beliebteste denn er ist sie
wir hoffen dass mit ihrer unterstützung
der polizei der entscheidende hinweis
gegeben werden kann
das amtsgericht berlin-tiergarten
becker ist mit staatsanwalt martin
klagen verabredet er hofft auf neue
hinweise aus der bevölkerung
das ist natürlich ein besonderer fall
nicht nur weil er in der öffentlichkeit
sehr diskutiert wird sondern weil er ja
auch besonders tragisch ist die familie
hat bislang keine kenntnisse wo ihre
tochter
verblieben ist anhand der vorliegenden
fakten zeugenaussagen und ermittlungen
der kriminalpolizei rekonstruieren wir
einen der ungewöhnlichsten kriminalfälle
der vergangenen jahre
was ist am montag den 18 februar 2009 10
und in den tagen danach passiert
einen tag vor dem verschwinden von
rebecca es ist sonntag der siebzehnte
februar 2009 10 ist rebecca noch mit
ihrer schwester verabredet ihre
schwester lebt mit der tochter und
rebecca schwager zusammen in einem
kleinen einfamilienhaus hier in berlin
britz es wirkt der ort sein an dem
rebecca bis heute zum letzten mal
nachweislich gesehen wird
die schwestern machen sich brauchen wir
sechs neue schule wurde für einen
entspannten abend
gerne bei ihrer zwölf jahre älteren
schwester jessica und dem schwager an
diesem abend sind die beiden jungen
frauen allein zu haus der schwager
arbeitet als koch in einem hotel und
feiert dort mit kollegen zusammen eine
verspätete weihnachtsfeiern gegen 23 uhr
gehen die schwestern schlafen jessica in
der ersten etage ihres hauses rebecca
wie so oft wenn sie zu besuch ist auf
der couch im wohnzimmer gegen 5.45 kommt
der schwager von der firmenfeier nach
hause auch in er legt sich im ersten
stock hin zu seiner farbe später kommt
heraus die anderen internet im haus
runter eingeloggt soll porno filme
geschaut haben gegen 7 uhr verlässt er
beckers ältere schwester jessica das
haus mit der kleinen tochter
wir wissen von einem foto das sie noch
an eine freundin geschickt hat am morgen
vor ihrem verschwinden das darauf
hindeutet dass sie eben zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch gelebt hat und
27 versucht die beckers mutter ihre
tochter ansehen
[Musik]
wieder versucht rebeccas mutter ihre
tochter zu erreichen doch wieder geht
niemand dran rebeccas mutter versucht
ihren schwiegersohn zu erreichen doch
der so die aussage bei der polizei
drückt sie zunächst wenig später meldete
er sich doch rebecca schwager geht
während des telefonats zum wohnzimmer
seiner aussage nach ist rebecca nicht
mehr da auch ihre sachen nicht für die
familie kein grund zur sorge rebecca ist
auf dem weg zum unterricht in der walter
gropius schule
davon gehen sie aus doch bis zum späten
nachmittag weit nach schulschluss ist
rebecca nicht zu erreichen gegen 16.30
der schock die lehrer gibt an sie waren
nicht
ihre eltern verständigen die polizei die
hält sich zunächst bedeckt
im alter 14 bis 16 die pubertät da
laufen jugendliche auch mal weg der
sachverhalt muss erforscht werden und
das dauert meistens eine gewisse zeit
rebeccas familie will nicht wahr startet
über die sozialen netzwerke eine eigene
suche nach der 15 jährige die
anteilnahme
dann ermittelt auch die kriminalpolizei
die polizei veröffentlicht am donnerstag
den 21 februar eine vermisstenanzeige
inklusive foto seit drei tagen ist
rebecca nun schon verschwunden
die bushaltestelle alt buckow befindet
sich nur 700 meter vom wohngebiet
entfernt ist ihr auf dem weg zur schule
etwas passiert
die zeugen geben an rebecca hier an
dieser bushaltestelle das letzte mal
gesehen zu haben
die buslinie ml fährt direkt zu ihrer
schule
diesen weg nimmt rebecca
die ermittler werten sämtliche kameras
der busseln aus rebecca ist darauf nicht
zu sehen
war sie überhaupt an der haltestelle
eine kamera in der bäckerei an der
bushaltestelle zeigt genau in richtung
bürgersteig doch auch auf den haufen
gar nicht zu sehen
alle zeugenaussagen auch die meinten sie
mit einer decke oder ohne deckel oder
was soll ich gesehen zu haben das konnte
nach einer weiteren vernehmung alles
relativiert werden und hat uns nicht
weitergebracht
versucht rebeccas mittlere schwester
vivien selber zu sehen mit freunden und
vielen freiwilligen läuft sie das
direkte umfeld im bezirk
wir gucken ob wir irgendwelche hinweise
finden eventuell ja was dabei hatte er
telefoniere jakob hier irgendwas
entsorgt wurde und einfach schauen
hinweis
die polizei veröffentlichte inzwischen
details rebeccas kleider schuhe und
rucksack der marke wenz ihre plüsch
jacke und handtasche den wohl ihrer
lieblingsband bts zudem eine
digitalkamera und diese lila decke aus
dem haus der schwester und des schwagers
all diese zum teil auffälligen sachen
sind bis heute nicht wieder aufgetaucht
die polizei bittet um hinweise
tage nach dem verschwinden von rebecca
die überraschung der schwager wird
festgenommen
heute um 10 uhr wurde in der früh
verkündet wer befindet sich seitdem in
untersuchungshaft
wir gehen davon aus dass nach so langer
zeit die das mädchen jetzt mittlerweile
verschwunden ist die auch sehr
zuverlässig gewesen sein soll dass das
mädchen auch vor einer eines
gewaltverbrechens geworden ist die
theorie der polizei rebecca hat das haus
nicht lebend verlassen der schwager hat
die 15 jährige und ihre sachen später
weg geschafft
umgehend wird das haus von
kriminaltechnikern durchsucht jeder
winkel überprüft die suche nach einem
entscheidenden beweis
wir haben keine konkreten hinweise auf
eine gewalttat auf eine straftat dort im
hause gewinnen können was auch letztlich
dazu geführt hat dass ein dringender
tatverdacht gegen denen ja immer noch
beschuldigten frage nicht
aufrechterhalten werden konnte die
ermittlungen ergeben am tag von rebeccas
verschwinden wurde das auto des
schwagers auf der a12 an der abfahrt
friedersdorf um so genannten kiesel auf
bezeichnet das kennzeichen erfasst das
thema wird eingesetzt und automatisch
kennzeichen nach denen gefahndet wird
bis zu drei monate werden diese daten
gespeichert
auch das spart uns registriert
zum ersten mal wird das auto am tag von
rebeccas verschwinden um 10 uhr 47 von
diesem key system von der kamera erfasst
was gab es für jemanden so richtig ist
zu tun am tag nachdem er erst kurz zuvor
von einer firmenweihnachtsfeier nach
hause kam und
nur einen tag später wird der renault
mit der auffälligen lackierung um 22 uhr
40 von dem krisensystem richtung polen
erneut erfassen und danach nicht mehr
der wagen ist vor der grenze abgefahren
einen grund für die fahrten unmittelbar
nach der beckers verschwinden gibt er
damals tatverdächtige nicht die indizien
deuten für die ermittler in eine klare
richtung
der beschuldigte ist in frankfurt oder
geboren und verwandte von ihm leben noch
in dem bereich zwischen berlin und
frankfurt oder
wir hatten durch die krise aufnahmen
hinweise darauf dass möglicherweise
die leiche von rebecca dorthin verbracht
worden sein könnte und haben deswegen
die suche um vorwiegend auf diesen
bereich konzentriert wurde rebeccas
leichnam in den wäldern zwischen berlin
und frankfurt oder versteckt
im februar 2009 10 herrschten milde
temperaturen die 10 grad hundertschaften
rücken aus durchsuchen wälder seen
sümpfe die polizei ist sich zu diesem
zeitpunkt sicher
wir wissen was passiert ist brauchen
jedoch beweist sie veröffentlicht am 06
2009/10 fotos des twingos und fotos des
staates
nicht wie hier verfremdet
klar zu erkennen trotz allem steht
rebecca familie zu
so auch in der mdr-sendung die spur
halten sie ihren spielern schuldig nein
gesagt nein sie haben immer noch kein
beweis trotz spurensuche leichen hunde
et cetera kam nichts dabei hausmann und
zwei bilder beweisen für mich nichts
die suchmaßnahmen der polizei gehen in
den wochen danach intensiv weiter das
problem das waldgebiet hier rundum
storkow ist riesig der renault twingo
wird auf spuren über grün zudem wollen
zeugen einen mann mit basecap bei mord
kummersdorf nach der a12 beobachtet
haben laut aussage renn dieser in den
wald zurück als er gesehen haben doch
alle ermittlungen bringen nichts sollte
rebecca tot sein und ihre leiche hier
irgendwo verborgen sein so gibt es laut
der ermittler die hoffnung dass das
wasser sie irgendwann freigibt und sie
irgendjemand finden kann der schwager
bleibt bei seiner aussage er habe mit
dem verschwinden nichts zu tun die
fahrten nach brandenburg begründet er
mit angeblichen drogengeschäften am 22
märz 2009 10 wird er wieder freigelassen
ein jahr vergeht bild berichtet
regelmäßig über den aktuellen stand bis
heute dem familie freunde und die
polizei nicht aufhören ich
selbst habe noch voraussichtlich 99
dienstjahre und würde mit der
zuständigen mordkommission gerne diesen
in diesem fall noch lösen die polizei
interessiert besonders wer kann angaben
zu rebeccas persönlichen sachen machen
die bis heute verschwunden sind gesucht
werden schwarze schuhe und ihr roter
rucksack der marke wenn ihr weißer
kapuzenpullover
bts rap monster ihre bücher und tasche
sowie ihre kamera und ihr iphone 6
wurden diese sachen jemandem zum kauf
angeboten außerdem wer hat ab dem 18
februar 2009 10 auffälliges im bereich
der a12 rundum storkow im osten
brandenburgs beobachtet einen renault
twingo mit auffälliger himbeer
lackierung gesehen und sich bis heute
nicht gewählt bei ganz zunehmenden
hinweisen bitte ich um
mitteilung an jede polizeidienststelle
oder eben an die polizei berliner
telefonnummer
030 4664
4 6 6 4 auf den internetseiten der
polizei können auch anonym die preise
gegeben werden ich würde mir wünschen
dass das verschwinden von rebecca
geklärt wird auch im sinne der familie
ihres gesamten umfeldes seit zweieinhalb
jahren muss endlich geklärt werden was
mit rebecca passiert ist
[Musik]
wo ist rebecca neusch